[Música]
y
desde la bienvenida a un nuevo episodio
de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos lleva a
haití la única región del noroeste de
síria que sigue en manos de los
opositores al régimen de bachar al asad
y que se ha convertido en el último
refugio para más de 4 millones de
personas de todas las revoluciones de la
primavera árabe esta es probablemente la
que tiene el balance más triste el
seguiría la revuelta de 2011 se ha
convertido en uno de los conflictos más
graves de nuestro tiempo en 10 años el
número de muertos se acerca a los
400.000
miles de personas han desaparecido más
de seis millones sirios han buscado
refugio en el extranjero y otras decenas
de miles han sido desplazados por la
fuerza dentro del país en cuanto a
bashar al-assad es el único líder
autoritario cuestionado en 2011 que
sigue en el poder una década después del
inicio de la revolución
el régimen sirio sigue utilizando las
detenciones arbitrarias las
desapariciones forzadas la tortura y las
ejecuciones extrajudiciales para
silenciar a la oposición en este caso
las fotografías se han vuelto pieza
clave para las familias de aquellos que
siguen desaparecidos
[Música]
i
y
delante
la región de idlib es uno de los últimos
enclaves en poder de los opositores
sirios como cada viernes desde hace 10
años
los sirios se han reunido para gritar
sus esperanzas los cantos
revolucionarios siguieron a los gritos
de movilización por los presos aquí
todas las familias están preocupadas
todas buscan a sus familiares encerrados
en las cárceles del régimen mohamed
saleh tiene 65 años y a pesar de la
lluvia y de los bombardeos del ejército
pro asad a unas decenas de kilómetros
acudió junto a otras familias para
seguir manteniendo el recuerdo de estos
desaparecidos tengo la esperanza de que
esta revolución estas manifestaciones y
los medios de comunicación saquen a la
luz la situación de los detenidos para
que sean liberados con vida y que
vuelvan con sus familias
[Música]
desde el comienzo de la revolución según
la amnistía internacional
82 mil personas han desaparecido en las
cárceles del régimen en it live como en
el resto del país es muy difícil para
las familias obtener información sobre
el paradero y la salud de sus seres
queridos encarcelados
mohamed saleh acude a la oficina de la
asociación de abogados libres de siria
con la esperanza de localizar a su
sobrino ghassan
esta asociación de abogados y activistas
se moviliza por todo el país en defensa
de los detenidos arrestados sin motivo
raramente juzgados y a menudo muertos
durante la detención debido a torturas o
malos tratos
hasan al hasan es el director de la
asociación en atar efe cada día recibe a
las familias de los desaparecidos y las
acompaña en su búsqueda
[Música]
podría haber algunas fotos y tratar de
identificar a casa no sé si lo reconoce
no sé
bueno mirar la otra información que ha
rellenado en su solicitud de búsqueda de
kazán pero todavía voy a hacerte algunas
preguntas más cuál es la fecha exacta de
su detención 2012
en qué mes en febrero mi hija me dijo
después de verlo cuando lo sacaron de su
celda había una malla entre él y su
familia dos personas me ayudaban a
caminar por ambos lados y sus pies se
arrastraban por el suelo su salud se
había deteriorado mucho les pidió que no
lo visitaran más por qué razón por qué
será torturado después de la visita
entiende cómo lo sabía porque después de
las visitas siempre torturan a los
detenidos y les pidió que no lo
visitaran más
hasan se ocupa ahora de más de 800
familias 300 de ellas en la región de
iliff
hay varias dificultades en primer lugar
la situación de seguridad en general
la presencia militar en la región
el conflicto y la guerra los bombardeos
nuestra asociación ha conseguido ganarse
la confianza de la gente hijos ahora
muchas más personas se presentan
nunca nos hemos publicitado es gracias a
la gente que nos hemos dado a conocer el
sábado los host
para ayudar a estas familias hasan se
apoya en una amplia base de datos el
archivo césar que incluye casi 55 mil
fotografías fotos tomadas son
recuperadas por un desertor sirio
mientras trabajaba en el hospital
militar de damasco
hasan las clasificó todas según la edad
y los rasgos distintivos que pudo
observar hay fotos que tiene que ver
algunas pueden coincidir empezaremos la
búsqueda con las fotos luego veremos si
podemos obtener información adicional de
los archivos de los antiguos presos
verlander
tiene que ponerse las gafas
[Música]
a este aunque fuera mi hermano no podría
reconocerlo
déjeme ver este está tan deformado que
aunque fuera mi hermano no sería capaz
de reconocerlo
cómo puede identificarlo vamos a echar
otro vistazo rápido
así entiendo
y gracias a los testimonios de antiguos
detenidos es posible encontrar
información y entonces se lo haremos
saber
y el jabón final quedaron ruiz como la
unión
confiaba en la juventud
no todos los detenidos fueron
fotografiados
así que hasan al hasan y continúa su
investigación con el testimonio de
antiguos presos conocer a este exrecluso
es muy importante porque estuvo en
prisión entre 2013 y 2019
estuvo encarcelado entre centros de
detención
nota martillo la prisión de sednaya y
varias dependencias de seguridad
no hallamos tarifa
esta no es la primera entrevista que
hasan realiza a abdul baseer al bazar
name el hombre fue puesto en libertad y
regresó con su familia
pero esto es algo fuera de lo común
conocí a una familia que pudo ver a su
hijo en la cárcel de sednaya que
caminaba con mucha dificultad su nombre
era gaza mohamed al salehia motors
ficcions detenido en sednaya y
originario de rooms no lo he visto pero
he escuchado su nombre antes
ha oído su nombre en la cárcel
acá no sé si mis compañeros de prisión
me hablaron de él
de maná que fue encarcelado con nosotros
pero no estaba en nuestra celda estaba
en otro lugar nunca lo conocí ni lo vi
con mis propios ojos
el agua la nana pero en realidad no
puedo ver por un ojo
necesito usar gafas antes no era así mi
memoria también se vio afectada por la
tortura
pero no he olvidado ninguna escena que
haya vivido allí a las otras
siempre recuerdo esas escenas no he
olvidado lo que vivía allí
a su humillación tortura muchas cosas
el único deseo que tenía no era salir
no creía en ello
usted sólo deseaba morir
[Música]
y poder descansar
y arena se acabaron y que no es feliz no
habla la gente
pude
activar omni cantería viajó de manto
arte
en tratar de ver la fría
más la detención es una experiencia
dolorosa la he vivido los prisioneros
dicen que es peor que la muerte cuando
sentí lo que sentían los presos cuando
yo mismo estuve encarcelado durante un
tiempo
bots
tengo un fuerte deseo de ayudar a estas
personas a salir de la cárcel
con los otros solo antitabaco visados
quiero ayudar a todas las personas que
son detenidas arbitrariamente y también
ayudar a sus familias
porque me afecta mucho
y por otro lado es mi trabajo y lo hago
con gran determinación y quiero
continuar porque he sentido el
sufrimiento de estas personas
hamburgo vendíamos amor frío la vieja
séptimo
en las calles de siria todos comparten
la misma herida invisible
como esperar el regreso de un marido
un hijo
un padre
después de diez años sin noticias
sigue trabajando duro también quiere
localizar al marido de amina abdullah y
su familia cree que sigue recluido en la
prisión de sednaya a 30 km de damasco
uno de los peores centros de detención
del país en primer lugar me gustaría
ofrecerle disculpas porque puede que le
vuelvan a la memoria recuerdos dolorosos
de la desaparición de su marido
vamos a hacerle algunas preguntas sobre
esto
tiene algún inconveniente con esto no
hay problema muchas gracias
en qué año desapareció su marido
en qué año 2012
no 2011
cuál es su nombre su nombre completo
cómo fue la detención tiene una fecha
exacta el día la noche la hora exacta a
las dos de la mañana los demás detalles
alguien llamó a nuestra puerta para
decirnos que el ejército venía a
arrestar a mi marido y de repente
llamaron a la puerta ni siquiera tuvimos
tiempo de pensar hacia dónde podía huir
vinieron empujar una puerta y entraron
ahumada fasa silva bufa registraron toda
la casa yo estaba sentado en una banca
en la esquina de la habitación
dañaron algo en su casa sí
[Música]
conocí a muchos antes de su detención
recuerdo después de 10 años
[Música]
cuando lo arrestaron intento averiguar
dónde estaba y conseguir un abogado
la pregunta hoy en damasco y me dijeron
si no ha hecho nada saldrá no se
preocupen
donde preguntó
pregunte a la seguridad militar que fui
a diferentes centros de detención fue a
la prisión de abra
no en una base militar en damasco
y no
puede describir a las familias que la
crisis no sólo de damasco de otras
provincias si gente de todo el país
todos hablaban un dialecto diferente que
todos vinieron a buscar información
sobre sus hijos venían por un documento
para poder entrar a la cárcel para poder
recibir información sobre sus hijos
estudian y tres veces en dos
oportunidades no me dejaron entrar
seguir buscando todas las veces me
decían que podría estar en otro lugar y
una vez hacer nada pudo entrar en la
cárcel de sednaya
frente no solo entre cerca de donde
estaban interrogando a los prisioneros y
me quedé parado donde estaban
investigando tenían las manos esposadas
y los traían uno por uno para
interrogarlos como había gente que
estaba esperando y deseando que mi hijo
apareciera la piba xix obligue que lo
interrogarán y lo soltaron busco las
fotos en el archivo de césar trato de
encontrar a su marido lo ha visto todo
no se encontró nada por lo general es la
esposa o la madre la que realiza la
búsqueda y consigue rastrear e
identificar a su marido o hijo así que
entre el año de su detención y todos los
años que han pasado los rasgos de su
cara deben haber cambiado mucho si
después de diez años por supuesto no sé
si podría reconocerlo
todos los días guardo la esperanza de
que vuelva a casa lo que me ha ayudado
es estar con mis suegros y mis hijos
[Música]
esperan que papá vuelva a casa algún día
lo esperan
preguntan si papá va a salir pronto de
la cárcel solo de la mamá
en seis años las investigaciones de
hassan al hasan han permitido
identificar a 30 hombres entre las fotos
del informe césar una gota de agua en
comparación con el número de
desaparecidos
[Música]
una información que luego se transmite a
la justicia de francia y de otros países
[Música]
desde 2018 parís ha abierto una
investigación por crímenes contra la
humanidad contra el régimen sirio con
base en estas fotos y testimonios
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta al día recuerda que si
quieres ver este y otros contenidos en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom
[Música]